ich habe den film wir oder das heißt im
original gesehen von dort fiel der
zweite film von jordan viel wie schon
get out sein debütfilm ist das ein sehr
guter sehr gruseliger thriller horror
film der aber sehr viel tiefer reicht
als es so ein unterhaltungs blätter
horror könnte also ganz auf der
oberfläche geht es um eine familie die
in santa cruz in einem ferienhaus urlaub
macht und die mutter die war auch schon
mal als kind dort und sie hat so immer
das bringt so ein gewisses unwohlsein
mit dass sie noch komische dinge in ganz
kurzen abständen wird was sowie zu
füllen seit wir hier in dieser gegend
sind erlebe ich und mir davon
ich denke ich das bedeutet dass sie
jetzt niag dieses unwohlsein trägt also
diese lupita mhlongo als
hauptdarstellerin mit in diesen urlaub
hinein haben wir auch die ganze zeit und
das bestätigt sich dann als nämlich
abends auf der auffahrt im ferienhaus
eine familie steht und das sind genau
eben die doppelgänger dieser familie die
dort urlaub machen und dann wird es ein
bisschen grausam
diese doppelgänger wollen sich nämlich
rächen für dafür dass man sie zeit ihres
lebens in untergrund abgeschoben hat wo
sie vor sich hin vegetiert haben und
diese rache nimmt dann ziemlich großen
teil des films ein
was seid ihr für menschen das sind wir
allerdings gibt es auch wie schon bei
get out einen unterbau dieser geschichte
also einerseits natürlich haben wir das
ganz klassische doppelgänger motiv das
stammt schon aus der romantik und in der
romantik wissen wir ja hat sich so dass
moderne subjekt geformt und dieses
subjekt dieses moderne subjekt wurde
dann eben in dieser romantik mit lotte
wir sind eben den gothic novels auch
verhandelt wurde von diversen dunklen
dingen angegriffen und angeknabbert an
allen möglichen ecken und enden von
vampiren von monstern von schatten und
eben auch von doppelgängern und auf
dieses alt doppelgänger motiv rekurriert
der film damit auch denn diese
doppelgänger sind praktisch eine art
seelenloser abklatsch dieser menschen
und es stellt sich heraus dass dieser
familie nicht die einzigen sind die
doppelgänger haben
die denken wie wir
was dann zunächst so ein bisschen
anfängt wie so eine art zombie
apokalypse die aber allerdings sehr sehr
gut gedreht ist auch ein sehr feiner
humor hat sehr gut gefilmt ist bekommt
dann eben noch eine ziemliche tiefe
jordan piel ist nämlich jemand der nicht
einfach nur also einfach nur horror
slacker filme dreht in denen es sehr
blutig vor sich geht sondern ist jemand
der immer auch gesellschaftliche fragen
mitverhandelt also bei get out wird ja
auch die rassenfrage mitverhandelt
eigentlich und das ist eben so das
verdrängte teil der amerikanischen
gesellschaft dass es eben das was da sie
ein bisschen in den schatten lauert und
genau so etwas gibt es eben auch bei
bayer ist bei wir aber was das genau ist
wenn es nicht die rassenfrage ist das
ist ein bisschen gemein zu klären weil
man damit sehr viel vom vergnügen das
endes und dessen was ich dann da so
ausrollt vorweg nehmen müsste und das
möchte ich natürlich nicht weil sie
sollen sich ja alle noch fürchten in
diesem film vorsichtig also es muss
schon ganz ordentlich das muss man
wollen und dann muss man sich auch
darauf einlassen aber wer das kann der
wird mit einem wirklich sehr
intelligenten film finde ich belohnt es
ist für den roboter oder
[Musik]
man merkt dass john peel einen sehr
schönen humor hat auch aus seiner
vergangenheit als comedian aber ich
glaube mit get out hat er schon so seine
richtung gefunden und ich glaube in so
geht das jetzt auch tatsächlich weiter
und geht auto hat hat dort auch selbst
geschrieben hat dann drehbuch oscar
dafür bekommen
und ebenso dieser film auch von ihm
stammt das drehbuch und ja man kann sich
vorstellen dass er bei der nächsten
oscar-verleihung durchaus auch
berücksichtigt wird
wir müssen weiter und immer weiter die
höre nicht auf bis sie uns getötet haben
oder wie er sie